My name is Neil Martin.
Um,
my title is I like to be known.
I am a author of habit.
The 95% of behavior marketers ignore.
And I am the founder and CEO of
intellect,
a consulting company in Atlanta.
The real idea just came from watching my
daughter use her cell phone,
you know,
teenager,
on the couch right beside the landline
phone and you know,
something occurred to her.
She was online and she just whips her
cell phone out and called a friend.
And you know,
the parent in me reacted like all
parents do like wait a second,
that one cost me money,
the other one's free,
you know,
use that one.
But then I realized that what she had
done,
she had done unconsciously and it was a
habit.
And so I do a lot of work with
communications companies and I really
started thinking about that idea about,
you know,
what we do unconsciously might explain a
lot,
a lot of the big problems with
marketing.
So when I did my phd in marketing was on
customer satisfaction,
and it was,
you know,
did all this research tonight,
all this complicated mathematical
modeling.
And then I did this,
you know,
large scale analysis of all this
research and discovered that customer
satisfaction tells us almost nothing so
that if I know how satisfied you are,
I cannot predict what you're going to do
it.
Yes.